[Música]
o
[Aplausos]
[Música]
não
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pô
[Aplausos]
as luzes vir em cenários pra espetáculos
de música dança teatro e hoje ganhou
tentar explicar um caso o processo vá
fazer isso e o que move para ter esse
trabalho que é um trabalho diante em
termos de estamos forma que estamos
poucas vezes que a família e iso muitas
horas e eu vou tentar falar esse
tormento adaptaram e atrás da hoje as
desculpas não foi muito bom fazer isso
eu penso em três palavras chave que
acompanham desde que eu faço isto eu
consegue ter um percurso normal letras
entrega direito
daí em direito estudo há cerca de duas
semanas andrew a 5
foi assim na altura em 2001
decidi que ia deixar daquela vida ficado
por influência do meu pai então na
altura no porto 2001 havia uma
necessidade muito grande de técnicos a
primeira grande leva de técnicos
formados em portugal foi na espanha e e
até 2000 e 2001 uma lacuna entretanto
abriu a escola superior de música e
artes do espetáculo que eu estou lá mais
um curso que não acaba aí tem 45 e na
altura fui trabalhar por dia de são joão
no porto e fez o normal
o projeto anos montá-lo superior à das
peças de teatro e uma das fases mais
avançadas quando já tinha capacidade
para tomar conta do espetáculo cruzaram
para o espetáculo com guião fazer o
teatro
só que eu sou uma xuxa se aborrece muito
facilmente
sei que é um trabalho muito positivo
porque uma peça está em cena às vezes
três meses e todos lisa igual e todos os
dias fazemos a mesma coisa
então nessa altura nessa altura que isso
emprego
salvo erro 60 anos e os um canto
esquecido com datas e essas coisas e
sair a pensar que não era aquilo que eu
queria fazer e que como tinha muito sua
design mas o tema são joão é uma
referência a nível mundial do teatro
violão e designers que é o que eu faço
mais ou menos estou eu comecei a ver o
entroncamento ter 200 peças de mobília
tarde existe e eu te amo e fazendo o que
como é que eu faria a iluminação para
aquela peça que estava a fazer
trabalhei lá com uma pessoa que é o
paulo brandão fomos colegas que depois
em 2007 e 2008 vai abrir o dia do circo
aqui em braga e eu vim a constituir aqui
pra iluminação e na altura tenho que
tirar a minha equipa
nós fazemos precisamente também é uma
casa de acolhimento que seria com
certeza mais fácil fazermos coisas
diferentes mas o que eu tentei repetir a
minha equipa e já que estamos aqui já
que vamos tentar aqui das oito da manhã
até às três da manhã
vamos fazer coisas que nos den 1
presente e pronto e trabalhei no theatro
circo mais uns seis ou sete anos depois
o fortaleza também e decidir fazer uma
empresa de iluminação cenário de vídeo
que o espetáculo seja ajuda com o apoio
da esposa que os primeiros tempos foram
foram financeira minha muito difíceis
porque eu estava cansado e não tenha
mostrado grande coisa e então fiz essa
de flex que é empresa de iluminação e
design cenário de produções vídeo
é o que nós fazemos não é pra isto foi
só para explicar o curso e uma das
palavras eu tenho um cartucho razão
porque como ele citou letra da lei
uma das palavras que sempre uma das
palavras que eu ia usar até fazer um eu
sou um caso das suas coisas para última
análise não deixar as coisas para a
última faz um trabalho melhor revelado
isso não se deve dizer isto é um mau
exemplo mas é assim que eu trabalho e
uma das palavras uma das coisas sempre
presente na minha vida foi a música teve
uma vaga de garagem com muita gente mas
eu todos os dias com sua música todos os
dias a pé quando ganhou uma filho no
tento que a nossa música e acho que não
conseguia viver sem ouvir música não
confia
isso é uma é uma das palavras que falar
e é uma das coisas que mostra os dias da
música e poder fazer o que eu acho que
eu faço que é uma narrativa visual da
música que está sendo tocado em pauta
vamos fazer isso ter o conceito em vez
de os gadgets de iluminação fazem mil e
uma coisas más e eu tenho que cuidar com
tem tecnologia tem que ter alguma alguma
algum conhecimento mas a tecnologia é
apenas uma ferramenta
o conceito que a gente tenta pôr em
pauta com isto é passou a explicar aqui
isto é é o cenário ou parte de alguns
pais haviam do último álbum depois e até
podem comprar o cd que ajudamos os olhar
eu acho que olharem para a capa de lênin
neste caso foi a capa do cd
a maior inspiração em uma linguagem que
eu já trabalho com elas há muito tempo
quando entrou o analógico e digital que
é o que os fazem tamanho com músicas é
uma mistura muito grande e isso é parte
do cenário e complementa
vamos ver não trouxe fotografias nenhuma
do meu trabalho e espero que um livro e
uma encontra em eu estou sempre a fazer
consertos e pronto é a segunda na
segunda coisa que moveu principalmente
fazer uma empresa em que move todos os
dias é falhar nós para fazer as coisas e
não podemos ter medo de falhar e eu nas
coisas que eu faço normalmente tento
fazer a coisa mais difícil é uma coisa
que é que há uma probabilidade maior de
falhar e para mim é o que faz avançar e
como faz criar uma linguagem eu acredito
que já tem uma linguagem visual que já
começa a ser conhecida pelo menos no mar
e esse sempre na minha cabeça desde que
eu comecei a fazer isso foi não ter
muitos olhares tiveram medo de falhar
vamos fazer o que é o que é confortável
não vamos sair do sítio nunca é o
conselho que eu tenho uma pessoa
extremamente organizada que os militares
a trabalhar e passo fico horas haverá
uma liga e na altura num não entendam
isso como desmanche eu tenho uma forma
de trabalhar que é essa e foi uma
ligação mais do eu com certeza fazer
duas coisas em meu nome nessa até eu
posso te levará cerca
mais uma vez na roça mas vocês pensarem
bem não fui me ligarem os desenhos
animados das regras regras físicas não
existem do peter griffin não podem subir
até e eduardo não existe nenhum e e pelo
menos um maior desde que o que eu acho é
que muito disso kloch o que o problema
de tempo fazer com que os músicos e os
santistas o formas nem tentam fazer
funcionar um carro e eu continuo a
acreditar e bastava ser a fase não é uma
palavra mas acho que é outro equipamento
e isso pode parecer ridículo fazendo meu
trabalho fazendo uma coisa bonita
posso mudar a vida de uma pessoa que eu
posso inspirá-la eu e acho que qualquer
um de vocês todos nós temos um alguma
coisa que estamos a fazer e tivemos aqui
um exemplo muito bons hoje durante o dia
todo na frase mas eu lembro da frase
deixar a fantasia
eu nunca fui assim a porta daquela coisa
que vocês que criam fazer seja tirar
fotografias é não só uma pessoa pode
querer ser o caixa do piloto não há mal
nenhum
desde que faça a mãe e é isso que eu
tenho uma equipa já grande faz muitas
vagas tem que ter colaboradores que
implica uma trabalho ajuda sobretudo
desenvolver os projetos e o que eu peço
é isso é não faça essa porta acredita em
si e acreditem neste momento nós vamos
fazer um conselho formado pelos aplicar
uma narrativa visual e podemos 1
é isso que eu quero fazer
eu faço tudo por acaso mas fiquei
deslumbrado as primeiras vezes que
trabalhei aqui isso foi
nenhum eu já nem está há 15 anos e
aquelas com isso eu cheguei a dar aulas
tamanho de iluminação e criando queria
falar dentro dentro desta coisa nunca
fechar a porta do tiro seguiram queria
muito falar nisso não já preço
aquelas pessoas que falam não sei muito
bem como é que se chama site motivasse
nós vivemos todos nós temos alguma coisa
especial para dar eu vivo a minha vida
assim minha mulher sabe isso o meu filho
é muito pequeno e não quiser passar esse
valor e eu acho que qualquer um
todas as pessoas têm alguma coisa pra
dar aos outros podem
nós temos passado os últimos anos as
últimas décadas
já tentaram ser espertos nisto é
trabalharmos imenso uma coisa acho eu
acho que a música é uma arte completa no
que diz respeito a isso porque há os
conceitos problemas ao vivo a música
começa quando eu acho que uma pessoa que
não seja tocada pela música que acho que
tem um problema grave porque seja lá o
que for seja aqui em barreiras o show
para o não entrasse
acho que é uma coisa natural homem a
música nas meses aconteceu muitas vezes
e ainda que não está sozinho assim e eu
dei aula se de uma experiência
especialmente com dois alunos um deus
trabalha comigo não a gente hoje em dia
trabalha comigo e outro está agora
agendado na na obra da doença e e essa
pessoa está em andamento e não sei se o
barbarismo recebido com um abraço pra eu
disse uma coisa uma vez um daqueles dias
que nós começamos a chefe da manhã e só
no quarto amanhã o outro lhe ainda
estamos a trabalhar e já é difícil até
falar e eu não estava um senhor estava
embaixo estava cansado e não diz uma
coisa que até hoje eu tenho isso na
cabeça que é nós temos um melhor
trabalho do mundo e eu acredito piamente
que tenha um melhor trabalho no trabalho
isso não é um emprego é o meu trabalho
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]